award-winning journalist mark Cooper was
a translator to President Allende until
the coup of 1973 in Finnish a and me he
reconstructs the tense atmosphere of the
final days of the IND government
including his hiding and subsequent
evacuation under armed un protection 25
years later he returns and describes in
vivid street-level reporting a country
that is a democracy in name only and a
society that has been transfigured by
one of the most radical armed capitalist
revolutions of our time mark Cooper's
journalism has appeared in publications
such as The New Yorker Harper's and
Rolling Stone he is currently a
contributing editor of the Nation
magazine as well as a host of the
nationally syndicated radio nation his
previous work includes the book roll
over che guevara travels of a radical
reporter Kirkus Reviews calls Pinochet
and me a powerful page-turner it's only
flaw as its brevity on that note please
welcome Mark Cooper
I didn't bring my telephone book
whispering huh
will do is best can you can you hear me
and see me all right thank you very much
for coming out tonight
I know it's extraordinary night in
Portland when it's raining and thank you
for coming to spend some time this is a
subject that's always a little bit of a
mystery to me because I've been so close
to it for 30 years it's always very
difficult for me to judge where the
interest of the audience is to me it's
an it's simple because I lived the
period of the yunda government so
intensely and it was a very intense time
and the period immediately thereafter of
the military coup was even more intense
even though I was only in the country of
eight days during that military during
the initial military regime I've been
back to Chile several times I'm married
into a Chilean family and I have an
ongoing connection with Chile I was
there as recently as eight or nine days
ago ten days ago and so to me it's part
of my life and it's ongoing saga places
like Chile don't get much attention in
the United States unless it's focused
through a national security sort of lens
and of course with the collapse of the
Cold War even that has become more
opaque so I say all that by preface to
say that I'm going to make a really
radical attempt to keep my remarks to a
certain economy and then take your
questions because I'm not really sure
where your particular interests are I'm
going to start with the personal side
just for a minute
because it's a question that comes up
and I'm going to get it out righted
right away and I did make an attempt
in this brief book to not tell very much
in my story because my story has some
interest but it's not very significant
compared to what is happening in Chile
but the question inevitably comes up how
did a kid like you from the San Fernando
Valley which are the flat suburbs of Los
Angeles how did some kid like you when
you were 20 or 21 years old wind up
being the translator to President
Allende and that can be a very long
answer or very short answer and the very
short answer is Ronald Reagan because in
that period that we're talking about
nineteen seventy or seventy one seventy
when Salvador Allende was elected that
was a time when Ronald Reagan was indeed
the governor of the state of California
I was a twenty-year-old college student
in my second or third year at State
University in the suburbs of Los Angeles
a very hot radical State University at
the time Oh kind of a junior Berkeley
and I was a very active and one of the
leaders and local anti-war movement on
the campus and I got into some trouble
with the administration for this and in
1971 by executive order of the governor
of the state of California Ronald Reagan
I was kicked out of the State University
system in fact I was banned from any
University practically in California and
I decided that might be a good time to
pursue my education elsewhere and I went
to Chile because I'd been studying it
and because Salvador Allende had just
been elected and it was a very exciting
notion and I got to Chile when I was 20
years old and I got a job in a state
publishing house which was more
felicitous than it sounds and through a
series of circumstances that are not
very extraordinary
moving from one job to another within a
year I wound up being the translator to
the present and when I started doing
that I was exactly 21 years old and it
is an extraordinary a privilege that I
had really extraordinary an
extraordinary experience to live through
what happened in Chile to have worked
with Salvador Allende and then to his
survived the military coup was an extra
treat and I dedicate the book to Ronald
Reagan and it is heartfelt because the
education while I'm a big defender of
public education and actually at some
level defend the state university system
in California I have to say that the
education I got in real life was better
than a state college education so this
one is for the Gipper it's not a phone
book but it'll do
how's that
now okay it is a it is incredibly it is
incredible that we actually meet today
the publisher of this book
verso publishers and I knew when we put
this book together we knew it would come
out more or less at a time when the case
of General Pinochet would be generating
some news we did not know that it would
be this week that it actually came to a
conclusion and it is hard you might be
scrunching your eyebrows and saying what
do you mean I read in the paper that
it's kind of like a ping-pong match he's
arrested he's not arrested he's out of
jail he's in jail he's indicted he's not
indicted it is indeed a very complicated
tale but let me cut to the chase and
tell you that it was precisely 48 hours
ago literally 48 hours ago on Wednesday
that General Pinochet was met at his
estate by a detachment of Chilean
civilian police like the FBI accompanied
by an investigating magistrate and
Pinochet was forced to sign the papers
officially putting him under house
arrest for the indictment that had come
early 48 hours earlier that was 96 hours
ago on Monday General Pinochet was
formally indicted on charges of the
murder kidnap disappearance of 75
civilians in Chile 75 out of more than
3000 of course that were murdered in
Chile 1,100 of whom were disappeared and
whose bodies were not found
there are coincidentally another 225
cases pending against General Pinochet
so if he should snuggle out of this one
there's another 224 to try but the fat
doesn't matter is that General Pinochet
has been detained it's a little hard to
follow but he's been detained three
times he was first detained by a
international arrest warrant in London
in October 1998 issued by a Spanish
Court I won't go into that detail
because it sounds kind of confusing and
he was held in British custody for 500
days he was returned to Chile a year ago
and then two months ago on the 1st of
December he was indicted by the
investigating judge that indictment was
overturned by the Chilean Supreme Court
on a technicality those technicalities
were overcome in the last two months and
specifically in the last 20 days and the
indictment they came down on January
29th is the real McCoy a General
Pinochet is appealing that and the best
that the general can hope for by any
informed analysis the best he can hope
for a couple of months out is that the
Chilean Supreme Court may excuse him
from trial for mental reasons that he's
not mentally fit to stand trial
now parenthetically I have to say that
the best publication in Chile is a bi
weekly tabloid whose title is the clinic
and for those of you who speak Spanish
the title of the publication is not la
clínica it is they actually use the
English words the clinic and it refers
to the London clinic in the United
Kingdom where General Pinochet was held
and originally in arrested in 1998 the
clinic a couple of weeks ago ran the
most brilliant front-page headline that
I had seen it was about three weeks ago
that General Pinochet was forced to
submit to mental exams court-ordered to
see if he was fit to stand trial because
Chilean law says that if you're over 70
years of
you have a right to be examined mentally
to see if you are either but the actual
words in the code are crazy to see
whether you're local crazy or demented
and and if you're crazy or demented you
can be excused from trial and the clinic
a couple of weeks ago ran this I should
have brought it ran this beautiful
full-page a headline that said really it
said the mental tests are superfluous
because only a psychopath would throw
bodies into the ocean
this came indeed at the same time that
news was made by the Chilean armed
forces at the beginning of this year
that for the first time in history
recognized that indeed they did throw
bodies into the ocean now all of this is
prelude to the following question what
difference does it make is this about
revenge is this about extracting a pound
of flesh from a rather decrepit 85 year
old former dictator when General
Pinochet is bloated and he is physically
diminished and often needs a cane or a
wheelchair his speech is off he probably
does suffer some mental degradation what
is this about and the answer is and this
is why it's so exciting to have this
book out at this point now the answer is
that this is not about the trial of
General Pinochet and indeed human rights
activists in Chile recognized that there
probably will not be a trial of General
Pinochet because he will probably either
be excused for mental reasons or he will
stretch this out so long he will simply
die before the trial that is why this
week it is really thrilling you don't
see it in the American press because the
American press is more interested in the
story of not a man biting dog but dog
biting woman
sweet if we could get 150th of that
amount of coverage of world events that
we would be very well off this the human
rights activist in Chile declared
victory this week they consider the
Pinochet case to be over whether or not
he goes to trial because what the
Pinochet case was about wasn't about
putting an old man on trial the Pinochet
case is about who is going to write
history and what that history is going
to be and what effect that has on
popular consciousness and taught now
that still might sound like a mystery to
you so I'll take it to the next step and
say that what is extraordinary about
Chile is that if you are here tonight
and you have enough interest in this
subject to be gracious enough to come
here this evening and you already know
something about Chile you already have
an association in your head you hear the
word Pinochet and it evoked certain
associations I'm going to guess and say
that those associations are dictator
human rights abuser a murderer torturer
and all of these are true the amazing
part is that of everywhere in the world
Chile has been the place that knows the
least about Chile
the things that we assume that everybody
knows millions of Chileans didn't know
because for 17 years they lived under a
military dictatorship that did not
permit that discussion and then in the
last ten years of democracy this had
been pushed aside free trade and a
privatized economy and a fattier right
kind of celebration of the free market
was pushed on the Chilean people as
values more important than understanding
their history and Chileans are pretty
smart there's 15 million of them I think
a lot of them knew what was
in Chile but it is the amount of people
that were in denial about this is really
striking because you think there'd be
nobody you'd think that even the
supporters of Pinochet would recognize
what would happen but would justify it
would say well yes three thousand people
were killed and eleven hundred
disappeared in eighty or ninety thousand
were tortured and a couple hundred
thousand were sent to exile but that's
the price you have to pay for freedom
that's not what you heard you'd hear
that no nobody was tortured these are
stories that are made up if people claim
they were disappeared they were
guerrillas who were killed by the
military because they were trying to
kill police officers and said it was
kind of science fiction a kind of
collective denial the wonderful news is
that the events of the last
two-and-a-half years since the arrest of
Pinochet and specifically I'm just
delighted to have been there in the last
two or three weeks a series of events
have happened in Chile that have
reversed that whole course of history
what has happened in Chile now is
undeniable and even the most ardent
supporters or former supporters of
Pinochet are those who stuck their heads
deepest into the sin now have to face
that reality right and it is
extraordinary
now I'll raise the next rhetorical
question why is it extraordinary what
difference does it make if people know
or don't know I'm going to use an
example that's right in our hands
because it's the best way I can
communicate this to an audience that
isn't Chilean I'm going to take a rough
guess and assume that there is not a
preponderance of Republicans here this
evening there might be a few Rockefeller
Republicans but I'm going to send there
aren't a lot of you if you're not a
Republican I want you to examine the way
you felt when George Bush was elected
president or when John Ashcroft was
confirmed as Attorney General
now these men and I need to say this
coming out of Chile these men are not
fascists they're not and we often use
that term very loosely but I suggest
that you don't because it is to be
disrespectful to those who really suffer
under fascism George Bush and John
Ashcroft are conservatives they are not
fascists and they're not Nazis and
they're not dictators and the rule of
law in the United States is flawed and
unjust but it exists and there's a
difference between a country governed by
even an unjust rule of law and a
government ruled by a military
dictatorship and we should never confuse
the two having said that look how bad
you felt having these jokers elected and
confirmed and it isn't it is a feeling I
know what it feels like you feel a sense
of frustration of shame or embarrassment
you say this is what my country has
chosen this is what people think this is
what we are for example if you
understand does that make sense to you
do you understand what I'm sure if you
can sense that then put yourself pleased
in the role of a Chilean who lived
through seventeen years of military
dictatorship if this Chileans IQ was
above room temperature they knew that
they were living in a authoritarian
military dictatorship where abuse was
the norm where people were murdered and
killed and raped and tortured and it
sounds like a cliche but it's true where
their bodies were disappeared where they
were thrown into lime pits or thrown
into the ocean literally where their
stomachs were slid open before they were
thrown out of the helicopter so that
they would sink to the bottom of the
ocean where they were buried in the
desert and then 10 years later had their
bones dug up and were throw
the ocean in case somebody would
discover the bones imagine living
through that for 17 years having then a
complicated political process which we
could spend hours talking about a
complicated political process then takes
place where the military dictatorship
retreats where democracy is restored
where there are indeed fairly clean and
orderly constitutional elections where
three succeeding civilian
administrations are elected a Congress
is elected you know it's like Kansas and
and the government that gets elected is
in fact even a government of opponents
of Pinochet and yet and yet seven years
into that that is the say Pinochet
leaves power in 1990 and in 1997 this
man is still commander-in-chief of the
army and a year later in 1998 it when he
retires his chief of the army he assumes
under the Constitution that he had
written 20 years before he assumes
legally constitutionally democratically
the title and position of unelected but
but actual senator for life and where he
not only becomes a senator for life that
is not an honorary title he's actually
in the Senate he actually in line to
become president of the Senate now
imagine how you feel then you pine for
John Ashcroft you dream of George Bush
you might even dream of James Watt at
that point because the sense of
overwhelming defeat is precisely that
it's overwhelming if you have a brain
you go crazy you say well wait a minute
we know what this may if you're if
you're aware you say we know who this
guy is
we know what he did the whole world
knows you may even have a relative who's
disappeared who had been tortured or as
in exile or isn't been jailed you say
he's the senator and there's an amnesty
in place that he put before he left and
not only can he not be prosecuted but we
have to call him senator and all of his
friends and all of his cohorts and all
of his accomplices and all of his
supporters are also senators and
deputies and director of the Chamber of
Commerce and whatever imagine the sort
of collective psychological trauma
that's inflicted upon you as a thinking
individual and then magnify that by
millions and you have a society that's
in very big trouble because you are an
absolute denial of your history and if
you are an absolute denial of your
history then you have no idea who you
are in the present and you have even
less of a clue where you're going and it
is a bad feeling let me just say in
passing Chile today has the highest
today has the highest index of
depression and of psychological problems
among the population of any country in
the hemisphere there's a reason this is
a country that is reasonably well-off by
South American standards this is not a
banana republic you know very
Europeanized country everybody's
depressed you would be depressed too
the incredible thing that happened was
that the mistake that mr. Pinochet
committed was that after having evolved
and developed a relationship with
Baroness Maggie Thatcher he decided on
one too many visits to London and in
1998 he went there to do some shopping
and he went there to visit Margaret
Thatcher
and the poor guy actually went there on
a public-relations offensive he actually
his family decided was time to improve
his image and they granted an interview
to The New Yorker and they thought they
were going to rehabilitate this guy's
image or buk buk it up because after all
he was now the senator for life he was a
respected old gentleman and there is a
wonderful salty old Latin American
correspondent British Irish descent
named Hugh o Shaughnessy who's written a
wonderful book called the politics
Pinochet the politics of torture and
Hugh lived in Chile as I did at the same
time and he wrote up what we call a
polemical op-ed piece if those of you
who are journalists have read up ed
pieces you know frequently op-ed pieces
are polemical they make a call for
something you know it's not really going
to happen but you make a call and it
became public in October of 1998 that
General Pinochet was in London and Hugh
O'Shaughnessy wrote a column in The
Guardian on October 15th I believe and
the title of that column was a murderer
in our midst and he said this general
was among us he was here in London and
he should be arrested for murder now I
know Hugh Shaughnessy and I know that
when Hugh wrote that column he never
dreamed and his wildest dreams that that
would actually take place within 24
hours but it did because some dutiful
clerk in Scotland Yard and we don't know
who it was I don't know who it was and
I've never read any article saying who
it was but some dutiful clerk received a
cabled message from Interpol it sounds
like a Sherlock Holmes movie he got a
cable of red alerts a red warrant from
Interpol transmitted from the Spanish
courts from a judge named Balthazar
Garcon and judge Garzon sitting in
Madrid teletype or cabled
just request over to Scotland Yard and
said we have an arrest warrant for
General Pinochet Britain and Spain are
signatories to the same treaty against
torture you are obligated to arrest this
man in this dutiful British clerk much
to the chagrin of Prime Minister Tony
Blair I assure you
said well this all looks in order and
sent out a detachment of plainclothes
Metropolitan Police known in the movies
as the bobbies and they showed up at the
London clinic and they disarmed general
Pinochet's bodyguards and pause they
placed him under arrest
poor Tony Blair the next morning leader
of the Labour government in the United
Kingdom had to say how wonderful this
was that they had captured this
international war criminal I'm sure he
immediately retreated behind the cameras
and met with his advisers and said now
what are we going to do and poor General
Pinochet was trapped and all I can tell
you is that that was a magic moment it
was the magic moment for me it was a
magic moment for every Chilean I know
and it was Chile as a land of
earthquakes and I want to tell you this
was about a 10.1 earthquake on the
Richter scale because General Pinochet
had built a regime and institutionality
and a political establishment had built
that just plain assumed that he was
untouchable and it is you can look for
all the similes you want you can look
for all the allegories and fables that
you want in all of the literary phrases
that you want but the best one is that
the Emperor had no clothes that was the
simple is that the man who was
walking around in an armored
impenetrable armor had it taken off by
these very polite bobbies and it came at
a time where you can't put your finger
on it but all you can say is that it was
a political earthquake and the
earthquake shook loose what had gelled
over in Chile I was in Chile just a few
months before General Pinochet's arrest
and to be crass about it it's probably
the best part of my book it's the part
that I think is the best where I
actually described what Chile was like
three years ago right before Pinochet
was arrested and I wrote it at the time
so I didn't know he was going to be
arrested I never dreamed he was going to
be arrested and in that piece I general
I essentially conceded the victory to
General Pinochet and said you want 25
years later you're the man you have
prevailed you know and how wonderful it
was to be wrong and how wonderful it was
to see those artifice is crumble now the
story of the crumbling is very
complicated and and I could not possibly
explain it to you other than to say at
the risk of being a little self-serving
I will tell you this that a week from
today next Friday I will have a cover
piece in the Nation magazine that
actually explains what happened in the
last two or three weeks it's very
complicated
but the last two or three weeks have
been the final day Numan it's really
been the final unraveling because the
real beauty here I'm going to wrap up
these remarks here the real beauty here
is not only that this happened not only
has all of the filth and all of the
horror and all of the truth come out not
only that but that in itself is good but
it's even better
because it comes at a time when the
Chilean military and even the Chilean
government made an extraordinary effort
to make sure it didn't happen it didn't
just happen in a void like everybody had
forgotten it happened against the
background where 25 years later 27 years
later the Chilean military and the
Chilean government unfortunately was
doing its best to make sure that this
was just off the agenda and the
wonderful part is that beginning about
the time that Kenny Shay got arrested
and especially after General Pinochet
got arrested the game plan of the
Chilean military and the game plan of
the Chilean government was to lay the
groundwork so that a law could be passed
in Chile that in Spanish would be called
a Punto phenol or a full stop and they
did this in Uruguay for example this
would be a law that would essentially
just shut down human rights cases and it
has completely totally and irretrievably
flopped not only flopped but it has now
become impossible in the foreseeable
future two and a half years ago there
were exactly two or three Chileans in
jail for human rights problems they were
in jail mostly because of the of the
Orlando Letelier murder in Washington
and special arrangement with the United
States allowed these couple of guys to
be prosecuted nobody else today there
are eight generals under indictment nine
if we count General Pinochet nine
generals a couple of them active duty
generals there's another 80 current in
militant former military officers under
indictment and I read just yesterday in
the Chilean press that the human rights
lawyers have another hundred
cases ready to file this week against an
equal number of military officers it is
costa-gavras made a film about Chile
called missing but he inadvertently made
another film about Chile called Z which
I don't know if anybody is old enough
here to have seen that it's a story
about the the military regime in Greece
and it does not have a happy ending but
there is a moment of triumph in that
film where there's literally a parade of
military officers being ushered in to be
indicted by a very industrious and
committed investigating magistrate and
that is exactly where we're at in Chile
they have to stand in line now to be
indicted so I'll be glad to to to take
your questions on any specifics or or
general and but we're going to give a
moment before you speak up to make sure
the microphone gets in front of your
face are there any questions we have one
right up here in front okay could you
address the depth of Ind I read several
different versions of it could you go
into that a little bit please the
question is could I say something about
the death of Salvador Allende himself
that has been an area of controversy
since the he died in the Moneda Palace
in September of 1973 since the coup I
have come to be I have come to be
friends and neighbors with one of the
Salvadorean these personal doctors who
was in the moneda at the time and the
palace at the time he's a good friend of
mine now I didn't know him at the time
we worked in the same place but I never
met him and from what he has told me and
from what I pieced together and I think
what a yin day's supporters have
accepted at this point I do believe that
cemetery and he killed himself
that was the version that originally was
circulated
as long as the military government was
saying it I mean there was a time where
General Pinochet could stand up and say
well that that's white and if he said it
was white and anybody with a brain would
say it looks white but it couldn't be
white because General Pinochet is saying
it's white there was a good amount of
disbelief about it I think that the
evidence is there is fairly compelling
that that on that morning of September
11 1973 and it is well documented in the
book the armed forces rose up they took
over everything they could they
suspended the Constitution they told all
the radio and TV stations to lock into
the military networker their antennas
would be bombed by aircraft they bombed
with a British Hawker hunter Jets and
the Brits have repaid the debt now but
using British jets Hawker hunter Jets
they bombed the presidential palace it
was on fire a general pin
President Allende was in the palace with
some of his supporters there's a
wonderful photograph that is the last
picture of Salvador Allende with a
military helmet on and with ak-47 in
hand and he did fight and he did fight
the the encroaching military and the
documentation that it exists would
suggest that as the palace was burning
and as General Pinochet Stroup's a
company which is roughly a hundred
troops entered the palace and as they
were advancing toward the room he was in
he took his life and
that's it next question Rebecca
I would add that while we're waiting for
the microphone together I think that it
was pretty much of I don't think that
Salvadorian he could imagine himself
being prisoner to these folks and I
don't think these folks could imagine
Salvadori a yummy being is their
prisoner either so I think I don't want
to reduce the gesture I think it was a
heroic gesture I don't know if I
certainly would have had the strength or
the conviction that it takes to make
that kind of dramatic decision but I
think if that would have been the end
result in any case I think Salvadorian D
knew that yeah I was very pleased when
Garcon Baltasar garzón brought the case
that actually had had Pinochet arrested
but I wanted to ask you there's been a
lot of debate about how this actually
came down and one of the criticisms from
people in Spain is that sure it's easy
to arrest and try fascists in Chile but
of course in Spain there are a lot of
fascists who are still around from the
Franco regime who and there it hasn't
been that similar sort of situation or
accountability in Spain the other
criticism which one read in the New York
Times and so I guess it's somewhat
suspect and I wasn't in Chile but the
question about Chileans arguing that the
whole arrest of Pinochet opened up the
wounds and sort of made reconciliation
more difficult so you could just comment
on those are two very incisive questions
and I'll take them one by one and if I
forget the second one remind me the
first question was isn't there a certain
hypocrisy to if you will among the
Spanish to go around and dogging Chilean
fascists and not doing anything about
Franco's fascists let's deal with that
question first it's an imperfect world
and I think that's an argument to be
made but I don't think that's the fault
of judge Garzon that is the political
that is a political institutional
problem in Spain judge Garzon is quite
an extraordinary individual
he was appointed as kind of a super
judge by the in quotes former Spanish
socialist government of Felipe Gonzalez
earlier in the decade or late 80s very
conservative government and judge Garzon
though appointed by this government
immediately said about to indict just
about everybody in the government on
corruption charges and drug charges and
he is a quite a modern hero not only
that he looks like a movie star and he's
about as perfect as you get as a
character and somebody will make a film
about judge Garzon judge Garzon after he
wiped out his own government decided
that he would look into the deaths of
300 Spaniards 300 Spanish citizens who
died in Chile and Argentina principally
during the dictatorships of the 1970s
and 80s that's a lot of Spaniards and
judge Garzon unraveled the network and
I'm not a conspiracy freak so I want to
underline that it sounds like a bad
movie but he unraveled what is known as
Operation Condor it sounds like a Robert
Redford movie that was three days of the
Condor Operation Condor was a real thing
run by the military dictatorships of
Chile Bolivia Argentina Uruguay and some
elements of the United States
intelligence services in the 1970s and
80s and it was a network of repression
it was a way that if a Chilean fled to
Argentina they could be killed and
disappeared in Argentina and if an
Argentinian an Argentine fled Chile fled
Argentina wound up in Chile or Bolivia
they could be eliminated there and it
was in fact Operation Condor it was a an
act of Operation Condor
that led to the murder in the united
states of orlando letelier's and it was
Operation Condor that led to the murder
of Army General of former army general
chilean army general Prats and buenos
itis a judge Garzon unraveled all of
that and all I can say is God bless him
your second question was a good one it's
about the question of whether it's
better for Pinochet to be tried in chile
or whether it opened up the wounds to
begin our this is wonderful this was a
the second question is how to what oh
how to respond to the notion that judge
Garzon arrest of General Pinochet in
1998 just opened up old wounds and made
reconciliation among Chileans more
difficult this was the operative excuse
a line this was the political line of
Pinochet's defenders and in a nauseating
sense I'd begun aye-aye
I like as a journalist and as a writer I
like to be inventive in my enrich in my
use of adjectives but I have every time
I come back to this point I always use
the word nauseating I can't think of a
better one the nauseating attitude of
the Chilean government because the
Chilean government composed composed of
Pinochet's opponents the moment that
this criminal was detained in London the
Chilean government got on its knees and
begged for his release it's you really
have to be I can explain that but we
don't have enough time I mean you have
to really understand Chile to understand
what's wrong with his Chilean government
that it would do that but nevertheless
that was the line well it's for you to
decide if you believe that you can
reconciliate while murderers and
torturers walk free while they are
elected to the Congress while they
become senators while they run radio and
TV stations while they're your neighbor
then I suppose that's right but I think
it's a ludicrous notion I know that was
the line but being in Chile at the time
was there any popular sentiment for that
maybe because people were in denial or
was it just a line from the government
very good question the question was
might be ludicrous but did people adhere
to that idea and was there actually
support for that idea in Chile at the
time the answer is absolutely yes
for several reasons there was a you know
there's 15 or 20% of that Chilean
population that is always going to be
Pro finishing why because they have
extraordinary class consciousness and
they make no bones about it
no pun intended they they are proud of
it and they are forever grateful for
General Pinochet for imposing their
class interests at the point of bayonet
and they will more or less tell you that
that's relatively small relatively a
little bit bigger than it should be and
then you have people who are victims of
the denial who you know like in our
country walk around in a somnolent state
all day repeating you know cliches and I
think there was a fear and it was an
unwarranted fear because there was no
physical reason to be afraid but there
was a reflex to be afraid because after
25 years of being you know there was 17
years where you could disappear if you
took demands name in vain right and then
there was 10 more years where it wasn't
really legal to do that and it didn't
really happen but it felt like it so
there was a certain amount of disbelief
and I have to say in passing in case the
Chilean consulate is listening that even
today the situation that I described to
you which is a positive situation is not
one that is even opportunistically
capitalized upon by the Chilean
government even today they will not
really
onto this even though from crude
political calculation you could down
really talking now about crude
calculations you can show one poll after
another in Chile where there is an Incan
census the New York Times sometimes
fudge assistance as well Chile's divided
well divided there's all sorts of
divisions right there's 50 50 and
there's 70 30 that's also divided 80/20
is also a division right there is an
overwhelming consensus in Chile depends
how you ask the question 60 percent 70
percent 65 percent 72 percent 80 percent
that justice should be done in some
sense the Chilean government refuses to
mobilize that politically so you have an
extraordinary political situation where
two-thirds of the country is clearly
that's a big majority in political terms
there are few political issues where you
get 65 percent you have a landslide
majority of two-thirds who is for
justice and then when elections come in
the last year the right is able to come
within a half a percentage point of
winning the election and the right in
Chile traditionally never got more than
thirty thirty five percent of the vote
right and somehow at the very moment
when General Pinochet is at his lowest
when his whole political legacy is in
tatters where in fact the right in Chile
has as well as its could as well as
capable has begun to turn its back on
him and at least ignore him at the
moment where they are most politically
bankrupt they are an electoral
ascendancy and the reason they are in
electoral ascendancy and we are
privileged as Americans because we can
understand this is that the average
Chilean can't tell the difference
between the right-wing coalition that
old Pinochet forces and the ruling
center-left coalition because the
differences between them are roughly the
differences between Republicans and
Democrats
and people look at it and the government
gives no voice to this anti Pinochet
sentiment if the government gave voice
to the anti Pinochet sentiment it would
mobilize hundreds of thousands of people
in Cleveland electoral majority the
problem is it would anger to economic
elites in Chile with whom and asked to
do business so it is a perfectly sorted
situation while we're waiting for that
question let me also tell you that there
are parliamentary elections coming up
this year and it's very likely that the
right wing will win them in spite of all
of this I was very impressed with
Christopher Hitchens article in the last
Harper's that seems to make a real case
that Kissinger was guilty of being a war
criminal in the sense of the death of
General Schneiderman the coup in Chile
and I wonder what your views on that
issue were the question is that recently
my colleague from the Nation magazine
Christopher Hitchens writing in a
different magazine writing in Harper's
holds a former Secretary of State and
National Security Advisor Henry
Kissinger responsible for the deaths of
Chileans and for his role in the coup in
Chile thank you for asking my favorite
question I'm sorry come so late in the
presentation because I could spend hours
talking about mr. Kissinger Christopher
Hitchens book the trial of Henry
Kissinger proudly published by my same
publisher verso will be available later
this spring and which mr. Kissinger in
which Christopher Hitchens in Deitz
Henry Kissinger and he indict him on
Vietnam on Cambodia and on Chile I've
just finished reading another fine book
called our Vietnam by Jack legis which
doesn't set out to indict Henry
Kissinger but
sure does for Vietnam
look the Nixon and Kissinger DeGette the
a nd government this is no secret except
to some Chileans and even that was in a
documentary in Chile a couple months ago
for the first time the Nixon government
plotted against a yen day we now have a
release of documents there's another
important book coming out later this
year by Peter corn blue which will be a
collection of the recently Declassified
US documents on Chile we've always known
the United States had some involvement
now we know more we know some of the
sums of money that were paid we know
that millions of dollars were given to
the Opposition in Chile to the Pinochet
forces we know that the Central
Intelligence Agency as you pointed out
dealt directly with fascist groups in
Chile that wound up assassinating the
commander-in-chief of the army
we know that the Central Intelligence
Agency had some knowledge perhaps some
participation in Operation Condor we
know that there is some pretty smelly
connections I'm not being suggestive
here I mean they're very complicated but
we know that there are some levels of
knowledge and perhaps operational
responsibilities of the CIA in the
actual murder of Letelier and we know
that Kissinger oversaw this general
policy I do not think that general
general I do not think that mr.
Kissinger will be indicted in the United
States of America I know that he will be
indicted by Christopher Hitchens and
that's probably a worse fate than being
indicted by a court he will be indicted
by Christopher in this book and you know
I'm not and I do know that Christopher's
intent actually in writing this book is
to actually provide the legal brief for
mr. Kissinger to be in
in the international court of justice at
the hague now this has happened before
you know the United States was convicted
in the International Court of Justice in
The Hague in the 1980s for its
activities in Nicaragua at that point
the Reagan administration decided it
wasn't going to recognize the
International Court of Justice and
nothing happened so I'm not expecting
mr. Kissinger to do any time in jail if
you'll allow me though I would love to
tell you my favorite anecdote that has
come out in the last year about Henry
Kissinger because it is just too
wonderful it is just too embarrassing
and too delicious a couple of years ago
and fortunately I can't remember the
official title of the book and I
wouldn't plug it if I did but Henry
Kissinger came out with the second
volume of his memoirs and in those
memoirs he characterizes the one
face-to-face meeting that he had with
General Pinochet and he had one
face-to-face meeting with Pinochet in
the spring of 1976 in Santiago and this
was at the height of the bloodletting
let me only say this was in the middle
of the frenzy there was literally blood
on the walls and in his memoirs
Henry Kissinger says and I'm
paraphrasing so don't hold me to the
exact quote but Henry Kissinger said
essentially that he told General
Pinochet he expressed to General
Pinochet the overall concern that the
United States government had about
possible human rights violations and
excesses of authority and told General
Pinochet that he should be more
attentive to these things and let him
know that the United States government
was looking over his shoulder
that's all well and fine there's only
one problem and that is about a year and
a half ago with the at the Gerald Ford
Presidential Library in Grand
Rapids Michigan they some of the Ford
administration papers were Declassified
and made public and among those papers
was the actual transcript of the meeting
between mr. Kissinger and mr. Kennish a
this is not conjecture this is the
official US government record of that
meeting and it's now been a year and a
half since I've read it and I have to be
honest with you and I can't remember if
the transcript was a verbatim transcript
I believe it was or if it was a
paraphrase transcript but nevertheless
it's the official record is taken down
by State Department stenographers and in
that meeting mr. Kissinger says to mr.
Konishi the exact opposite this I'm
going to withhold my adjectives this
functionary of the United States
government mr. Kissinger looks at
General Pinochet and he asks he begs an
apology and he apologizes to General
Pinochet for the contentious statements
that have recently come out of the
United States Congress who's been upset
about people being murdered and killed
and a general again mr. Kissinger says
to General Pinochet essentially don't
pay any attention to that we support you
fully more horrifying and I refer you
you can actually see this online so I'm
not I don't want to be quoted directly
and I don't want this I don't want to
characterize this improper lane you
should check this out yourself if you go
online and you search for the national
security archives which is actually a
nonprofit organization that declassified
documents you will see these documents
online and you can make your own
judgment and you can get the exact
quotes but worse at that meeting General
Pinochet complains
he complains to Kissinger about the
behavior of orlando letelier's a former
ambassador from salvador allende's
government a chilean leftist who at that
time was living in exile in washington
and had become the chief lobbyist
against the military regime he was
lobbying the IMF in the World Bank to
not provide multilateral funding for
Pinochet and he was lobbying against us
support for Pinochet and Pinochet loudly
complains to Henry Kissinger about
orlando letelier's Rica's enger'
essentially says nothing and of course
it is three months later that General
Pinochet eliminates Orlando Letelier
with a car bomb in the middle of
downtown Washington so it is an
excellent question that you asked the
Kissinger himself and the Ford
administration are up to them and the
Nixon administration primarily are up to
their neck in this and we know a lot
about it but justice is often slow and
elusive you have a question over here
I think maybe we'll take two more
questions because I think we're running
out of time yes my question is about um
the years 1998 when I I felt at the time
also I completely agree with you that
people were and the whole news that was
coming out of the country was that
Chileans were very unsupportive of
Spain's position that they'd taken on
arresting Pinochet and they you know
wanted their hero to live free and have
you know a happy rest of his life but
and and then two years later in the year
2000 correct when Lagos was elected who
is the current president and socialist
yeah I what's your perception of that
well
all that Lagos says no in the air
whooshing like the question is how is it
possible that in 1998 in seeing that
most or many Chileans were actually
supporting pin che when he was arrested
in London and only two years later a
socialist opponent is elected as
president and how polarized is the
country it is a good question but it
relies on perceptions that are not fully
accurate it is not true that in 1998
most Chileans thought that there was
some injustice committed by general
Pinochet's arrest what there was is
there was a very small but very noisy
and very exercised minority that took to
the streets right and chile is one of
the few countries where rich people come
out and demonstrate in the streets it's
really quite a spectacle it is really
extraordinary I have been in front of
General Pinochet's house unfortunately
twice over the years on his birth date
and it is one of the most surreal
experiences you could ever see in your
life and it reveals all of one's
prejudices because and I admit freely to
my prejudices Chile is I'm going to
answer your question Chile Chile Chile
is a third world country regardless of
some of its protestations it is a poor
country and half the country lives at or
near poverty and half of the country
doesn't and the people who are
comfortable are very comfortable and
there's even a racial divide that nobody
talks about it's very much an apartheid
society and the ruling elites are
lily-white and European and most the
rest the population is is darker
complected and mixed you know not a lot
of Indian or indigenous blood but enough
to to dilute the gene pool from the from
the rich neighborhoods and as an
American no matter what it is I'm not
going to ascribe this to you I'm going
to speak for personal title I freely
admit my prejudices and when you go and
you're among the rich people they look
more like people I know I mean you know
they're better dressed in there
better groomed and you know they have
real suits and ties on and expensive
glass frames and their nails are
manicured and they have on colorful sort
of floors or woody bandanas and or and
and there's kind of an assumption made
you look at them say oh these look like
the folks you'd see you know around
Harvard or well you know Berkeley or
Stanford and it's true you would in fact
most of these folks did go to Harvard or
Stanford or something like that and and
and I freely admit to my bias that you
figure that richer better educated
people well they're a little bit less to
less prone to excitability and outbursts
etc and yet you go and these are the
folks who are outside of general
Pinochet's door jumping up and down and
dancing to German marching hymns
literally you know and bowing and
thanking him and saying oh please thank
you thank you so much for killing all
these people in our defense I mean it's
a simplification but he's extraordinary
these are the people who took to the
streets when General Pinochet was
arrested it was the upper-middle class
came out in the streets and tried to
sack the British and Spanish embassies
it was really a straw Denari
moment and the Spanish Embassy is
located in a in a rich suburb of
Santiago in the mayor of that suburb is
a former military colonel Colonel lob a
big supporter General Pinochet and as
soon as General Pinochet was arrested
Mayor lebay cut off garbage services to
the Spanish Embassy so that has to rot
in their garbage so the reporters love
this I mean this is real fodder for
reporters because you go out and there's
a thousand or 2,000 people in the street
that's all there was
there was a small minority couple
thousand people who were I'm sorry but
they're hysterical
yeah just hysterical and these are
people I have interviewed Colonel lebay
and interviewed Colonel obey in 1998
and I'll be perfectly frank when I
interviewed him I I I didn't let him
know that I was a former translator to
salvador allende
uh uh and he was very different towards
me very off-putting in and I realized in
the course the interview that he was he
didn't like me and the reason he didn't
like me now this is going to be a trip
for you the reason he didn't like me is
because I was an American and according
to him the American government has just
been so outrageously left-wing and it's
criticisms of Chile that's just part of
some international socialist conspiracy
to in to disfigure the history of the
noble Chilean military regime so he
actually looks upon Americans as the
American government is left-wing metal
errs and this is the kind of now we're
getting into fascism yeah now we're
going way beyond John Ashcroft and Gale
Norton we're way on the other side right
so the answer to you is that there was
only a small and noisy minority the
incredible part is I hate to quote
Richard Nixon there was a huge silent
majority in favor of Pinochet being
arrested but you see the Chilean
civilian government that is putative ly
socialist and Christian Democrats as the
opponents of Pinochet they were begging
for Pinochet's release so you had an
extreme right and a right politically on
that issue right so if you were a well
thinking Chilean and I go back to what I
said an hour ago where you're into this
kind of collective psyche code psychotic
denial imagine what you felt like then
here the guy finally gets arrested and
the Chilean government that is composed
in part by the Socialist Party which was
Salvador Allende's party and there were
actually people in the government
including the current President of Chile
Lagos who had to go into exile and there
are other lower-level functionaries the
Chilean government
tortured there on the telephone asking
the Foreign Minister the Foreign
Secretary of great of the United Kingdom
to release the dictator it really is too
rich for words
it really is nauseating so there was no
political mobilization around that which
then explains your second question the
second question was well how did the
Socialists get elected against this
background last year the Socialists who
got elected Ricardo Lagos was actually
the government candidate this is a
governing coalition of Christian
Democrats and socialists for the last
ten years the Socialists have been in
the government as junior partners for
the last ten years and now as a matter
of political patronage of sorts of other
words also a primary but it was pretty
much cooked behind the scenes it was now
the turn of socialists to lead this
government but these Socialists in Chile
are and I am no fervent supporter of the
former clinton-gore administration I can
tell you that but the clinton-gore
administration are like you know sixties
radicals compared to the chilling and
socialist Chile is a place where there
is no legal divorce and where the
Socialists have not done anything about
it it's a country where there is no
therapeutic abortion period for any
cause and there are women in jail not
for providing abortion but for having an
abortion so we're not talking about a
particularly enlightened or progressive
regime let's take one more question and
I can talk to you separately yes
what about john ashcroft and our in our
denial about the latoya case i
understand that janet reno is close to
issuing indictments and what's gonna
happen now what do you think like that
that is such a great question to end on
thank you for asking the question the
question is what about john ashcroft
what about the Justice Department what
about our own collective denial isn't it
true that Attorney General Reno was on
the verge of and dining General Pinochet
I'll give you the five minute answer and
we'll be done it is a it's been it's
been I feel privileged to live through
this because it is always great to go
into the middle of middle age and have a
lot of your assumptions challenged I can
tell you with absolute certainty and I
know it is difficult to believe but it
is true that there are there were as of
January 20th career prosecutors in the
United States Department of Justice and
that there are in fact federal
investigators we better known as FBI
agents who really do honestly want to
indict General Pinochet for his role in
the murder of orlando letelier's in
washington d.c in 1976 and there is no
statute of limitations on murder and i
don't have to even speculate it a
certain i know that for a fact you don't
have to take my word for the following
point because it's a public record back
in August of last year
the United States Justice Department
sent a official list of sent to the
chilean courts a list of 42 people that
the Justice Department wanted to
interview better known as question in
relation to the
case it took the Chilean government
several months to respond actually was a
year and a half ago and then late last
year the Chilean government relented and
United States Justice Department
investigators were in Chile last year
and under the the compromise that was
made is that the Chileans didn't let the
Americans do the questioning but the
Chilean magistrates questioned forty two
suspects in the presence of these US
investigators or at least gave the
transcripts to them that is to say that
40 some-odd people in Chile were
questioned as recently as last year by
the United States Justice Department
investigating the death of the telly it
is true that there was a debate inside
the Justice Department and there was
some indication that the Clinton
administration or the Reno Justice
Department however you want to put it
was going to indict General Pinochet we
now have a transition and John Ashcroft
is Attorney General I'm going to say but
I don't know I wouldn't rule it out I
wouldn't rule it out I don't think we
should be blind about that I think that
sometimes you know Tony Blair didn't
want General Pinochet to get arrested
but he got arrested because there's a
certain independence of the you know as
as as cooked as we think the system is
there's all these little margins of
space that you then honest people can
operate in some of these investigators
in the Justice Department are career
prosecutors and they're still there so I
wouldn't rule out an indictment by the
United States what I would say is I
actually think it isn't the Bush
administration that is the biggest
impediment to the possible indictment
I'd say that fortuitously or otherwise
probably some of the steam to indict
finish a United States has been lessened
because he's actually been indicted in
Chile
and there may be a notion of well it's
overkill at this point you know we would
love to see the indictment we would love
to see the indictment at this point the
United States uh I'll just say in
closing one of the more of horrendous
acts that the Clinton administration
carried out in its final days you know
you got mr. Clinton got a lot of
deservedly bad press for the mark rich
pardon etc but one of much more
significant than that and virtually it
was in the New York Times in one article
but unremarked was that in late December
the Clinton administration approved the
sale of a dozen f-16 fighter jets to
Chile that Chile does not need and that
the region doesn't need and it's two
things that play there one this is the
Lagos government gift to the Chilean
military you know where some of you are
getting indicted but don't feel bad
here's a fleet of new fighter jets that
cost a billion dollars that Chile can't
really afford the dastardly part of this
by the Clinton administration is that
this breaks a 20-year freeze on the
introduction of sophisticated weaponry
into the region so you know even the
Bush administration didn't do this the
old Bush administration even they
respected that ban and these guys
Clinton and gore went ahead and said
well it's okay we're leaving office have
some fighter jets so right now there's
that deal pending and then more
importantly the United States is
currently began under Clinton last month
and is now continue knighted States is
now negotiating a free trade agreement
with Chile as the first step and what it
hopes is a free trade area of the
Americas so that may there may be a
political calculation made in any
ruffling of the feathers so I would have
to say that you know the chances of the
United States in dining the general
they are diminishing quickly I want to
thank all of you it's been really a
great discussion I encourage you to buy
the book I'll be glad to sign it and you
know we can chat then thanks so much for
great attention thank you